in a dramatic move to stop the spread of
the corona virus President Trump has
ordered an extensive travel ban we will
be suspending all travel from Europe to
the United States for the next 30 days
the new rules will go into effect Friday
at midnight these restrictions will be
adjusted subject to conditions on the
ground the State Department also issued
an alert last night urging Americans to
reconsider any international travel
plans Paula Reid is at the White House
for us Paul oh good morning the
reactions are coming in overnight what
are they a good morning Tony while the
president's goal was to calm the markets
and calm Americans but investors were
underwhelmed US stock futures tumbled
sharply as the president concluded his
speech and Democrats criticized the
president for not addressing the lack of
testing kits but a top White House
adviser just responded to this criticism
and he tells me that the president quote
signaled he is taking decisive actions
for the American people based on sound
science and there will see more of this
in the coming days we made a life-saving
move with early action on China now we
must take the same action with Europe in
one of his most sweeping measures to
combat coronavirus President Trump
announced temporary travel restrictions
on foreign nationals from several
European countries and laid blame on the
EU for not doing more to stem the spread
of the virus the European Union failed
to take the same precautions and
restrict travel from China and other
hotspots as a result a large number of
new clusters in the United States were
seeded by travelers from Europe the
president said restrictions do not apply
to the United Kingdom or Ireland and
will have some exceptions for American
travelers but didn't offer specifics
some Democrats immediately expressed
skepticism it applies to countries where
there's less of a problem in Europe but
not where there's more of a problem
elsewhere like in South Korea the
president also laid out a series of
steps intended to blunt the economic
impact of the virus including
low-interest loans for small businesses
deferred tax payments and a proposed
payroll
cut my fellow Americans president
Trump's address marked a notable shift
in tone just one day earlier when he
emerged from a meeting with Senate
Republicans to downplay public fears but
the National Institute of Health dr.
Anthony Fauci offered a grim prediction
on Wednesday warning of more cases to
come we've got to assume that it's gonna
get worse and worse and worse the
president has said for days that he
would not cancel his upcoming campaign
events but last night the White House
said it would be canceling upcoming
events in Colorado Nevada and Wisconsin
where the president would have been part
of large public gatherings White House
said they are doing this out of an
abundance of caution Tony
caution is the word of the day Paula
thank you very much